to change your life you have to be
willing to change your actions the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over and over again and
expecting a different result if you want
to change your life you want to be in a
different spot you have to be doing
different things now if you love your
life great don't change anything or you
love pieces of your life don't change
anything about those pieces but if you
are not happy with where you are at you
must be able beware
be one things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and in our IG live one of the
things he said was well I'm not
comfortable doing that we're talking
about making making content some days
he's on top of the world and feels great
and other days he's not and he doesn't
feel comfortable getting in front of the
camera when you say I'm not comfortable
doing that we have to identify that as a
trigger to go most of the things that
you're not comfortable doing are failing
in front of other people at the end of
the day that's what it is you're afraid
of being judged hey it's Nina Michael
and we made these videos because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of off more and you need a push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan Carmichael and learn
that you need to stop doing the same
things and expect different results
enjoy
because if all you did was wake up and
do what's in your comfort zone do what
is known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs as you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is a thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountables that you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
it's not against your value system right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I wanted to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 when we hit
23 cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know a quarter of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things the willingness to show up even
if you don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
insert to accomplish your goals and so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today look the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before it's why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving their job today hey most
people wake up all you know look at all
these cars here most people here in this
parking lot they're picking up every day
and driving to a job that they hate they
do not like their life most of the
people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing now try to get to the
reason behind the reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
know the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid of one people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
failure if it's fear of not being good
enough if the fear of being imposter if
it's fear being uncomfortable whatever
your actual fear is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period rule number two try
different things there's a reason why in
my videos I say you have Michael Jordan
level talent I believe it it's true you
you have Michael Jordan level talented
something you are the best the absolute
best at something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that their world
class has something or two they found
the thing that they could be world class
at but they don't have enough guts to
chase it down they don't believe in
themselves enough to chase them down
here's the thing
you need to First explore you need to
explore you gotta search you got to say
yes you got to try things you don't know
that that Tim Hortons is your favorite
coffee cup until you've tried it right
you don't know that Sushi is your
favorite food until you've tried it so
she doesn't make sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it Sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish mix it with rice put
seaweed around it and then eat it that
sounds nasty right if you've never tried
it before it sounds nasty but best
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you are
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling
the most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it I expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again
and so for me in helping entrepreneurs
I had my first speaking gig in in Canada
at a local YMCA
and I just sold my business young
entrepreneur success story I was 22
years old and I'm speaking at the YMCA
and they book off this big room for me
and they have an entrepreneurship
program and they say hey can you come
and speak to our entrepreneurs yes you
know I'm pumped I don't know what I
don't know what to do next with my life
anyway because I just sold my company
and I want to get back and help so yes
let me come and do it and I prepare for
two weeks making my presentation and
they're promoting it to their audience
for two weeks and then I get to the
building and my Palms a little bit
sweaty and I'm nervous my heart's
beating to get up the elevator walk to
the door
and my heart stops for a second because
I look into this big room and only three
people showed up three people to a free
event and in my head I'm thinking how am
I ever going to turn this into a
business right how will I ever turn this
thing into a business if I can only get
three people to show up to a free thing
with a partner but I did my presentation
anyway I prepared it in one of these
three people down
and it was the best
it filled me up so much knowing that I
helped these three people out I can't
tell you how great I felt and then we
went to the coffee shop after and
continued talking throughout the rest of
the night and I knew that I had to find
a way to keep going even though it made
no logical sense and here I am
I'm 39 now I was 22 right still doing
what I'm doing just on a bigger level I
could not tell you that I would be here
I had no idea what it would look like
you need to wrap your heart around it
you need to try you need to first start
by believing that you have Michael
Jordan level Talent on something that
you can be the greatest in the world
that's something you you can be it and
whatever lifts you up on a daily basis
you need to believe it you need to
understand you need to see it every day
because a one-off day is not enough
and if that means you're watching one of
these videos is why I made this channel
if this video helps you great subscribe
and watch the other videos or if it's
somebody's podcast or doing an act of
kindness and holding the door for
somebody or listening to you know an
audio or or reading the book something
anything whatever makes you feel like
you believe in yourself and your
abilities even though your ideas are
really weirdly different compared to
what your family wants you to do right
chances are the thing that you are
Michael Jordan at is not what your
family wants you to do
because your parents probably aren't
Michael Jordan what they did right they
settled and their advice therefore is to
have you settle as well
no
Not Gonna Fly
I got Michael Jordan level talent and
something I'm gonna figure it out and so
whatever gets you into that mindset of
believing it you need to be around daily
you need it you need a part of your
morning routine whatever that thing is
has to be in your morning routine
because if you wake up and did the thing
that made you feel confident made you
feel bold made you feel alive every
single day man your life is going to be
dramatically different it just will
there's there's no chance you're the
same person in a year there's no chance
you're in the same situation in a year
no chance not if you wake up and felt
bold that the thing that made you feel
bold you won't wake up and naturally
feel bold
you have to inject something in what is
the thing that makes you feel bold and
doing that every single morning it will
change your life
and then when you find the thing that
you have potential at that energizes you
that you love
you go all in on it you spend more time
doing it you invest in yourself to
potentially become the best in the world
I wasn't a natural speaker I wasn't a
great speaker took me 6 000 videos to
get to where I'm at right now a lot of
speaking a lot of practicing a lot of
coaching you can't get great at anything
it's just a skill set you can learn any
skill set but the thing that will give
you the drive to learn the skill set to
be the best is the Love of the Game of
The Craft of the thing and it all starts
from you deciding that you are Michael
Jordan at something also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three 3 treat money as
a tool most people grew up with an
unhealthy view of money some people
think that money is everything that the
next person you see the next customer
you talk to that's your next suit that's
your next car and other people think
that money is the root of all
right or the love of money is the root
of all
evil right to make money you're evil
you're slimy you're gross you're ripping
people off most people grow up in one of
those two camps that's the lesson that's
been taught you by your parents the
truth is money is just a tool money is
an amazing tool that lets you accomplish
amazing things and if you are an
entrepreneur and want to have success
making money has to be in your top five
list of priorities if it is not in your
top five then you're not making money
but it can't be number one money can't
be your number one priority there has to
be something that is more important than
it and that's your purpose I don't
really usually talk a lot about money on
my videos
um maybe I should maybe I should talk
more about it I think it's important I
think there's just so much out there
that seems to be money money money money
that I'm trying to go against it to say
like purpose is number one you have
you're built to serve if you're just
chasing money you're never gonna win I
think I see too many entrepreneurs just
chasing money and so a lot of the
content that I make is more Purpose
Driven but there's still there's still I
think a lot of people who are Purpose
Driven who've started the business for
the right reasons and they don't know
how to make money and so maybe I need to
switch up some of the content that I
make as well to help change the
perspective of our money my personal
view is I hate spending money till I'm
making money
I love making money it's not number one
right serving believing entrepreneurs is
number one but again it's in the top
five because if I didn't make money I
wouldn't have a team I wouldn't have
people to help me make this video it'd
be me by myself trying to put together
one piece of content you know a week or
maybe a day just you know filming by
myself but instead I have this team
people who I'm super appreciative of and
I can afford that because I'm making
money doing the business that I'm doing
right kind of important when I look at
Jeremy who
I invest into earlier this year this is
this is a great example of how I like to
think right so Jeremy runs a YouTube
Consulting business I invested into him
I had this dream in the desert I'm
driving through the desert on my tour in
March
ish in February around there this year
2019 and I had this idea that Jeremy I
want to start a YouTube Consulting
business with Jeremy at the time Jeremy
was working at a grocery store stocking
shelves and checking people out uh he
asked me a bunch of times whether he
could help me in any way if you could
walk my dog or buy groceries or like
anything just to just to help and I'm
like I don't need a I don't need
somebody to wash my car or walk my dogs
and so you know I said no but I love his
hustle and energy and drive and just
personality and I thought he'd make a
great entrepreneur and he's capable of
so much more than just working at a
grocery store
and so I had this dream in the desert
for some reason without a dream I was
driving so I was fully awake I told Nina
we need to get Jeremy on the line right
now
uh I had this idea so she messaged him
on Facebook and I said I need to talk to
him right now and at first he wasn't
available and said like you gotta get
him on the on the Facebook live right
now like I need to talk to him on the
video right now
because if I waited till tomorrow I
would have I would have pushed it off
right I got an inspired idea let's go
and I said here's this idea I've got I
want to teach you YouTube I wanna I
wanna have you learn everything that I
know about it and I want to start a
YouTube Consulting business with you and
here's what you need to do are you aware
and he said yeah I'm in I want to do it
he didn't really know a ton about
YouTube at that point in time besides
coming to my thought Leadership Academy
the the I guess the couple months before
and I said okay before I come back I'm
gonna be home in two months here's what
you need to learn you need to watch all
of these videos where I talked about
YouTube you need to watch these other
channels and talk about YouTube you need
to analyze data you need to come up with
suggestions and feedback and you need to
know what you when I come home I was 90
days on the road when I come home you
have to learn and know and understand it
you got to be an expert
and he's great at learning so I thought
he would crush it where I thought he
might struggle is on the interaction and
talking to clients because he hadn't
done that work before so when I got home
the first step was
you're gonna you're gonna hop on a free
call you're gonna get some free advice
to people who've come to the thought
Leadership Academy and do YouTube audits
on them uh tell them you're going to
record the call and then I'm going to
listen in with you afterwards and he did
a great job
it I knew he'd be prepared and have the
research and know what he's doing
because he he studies and he works like
nobody else but I didn't know he'd do so
well and actually being able to handle
the objections and handle the the push
and the movement to help them and he's
only gotten better with time too but
this is this is this is since we started
the business together in April
and he's already building a six-figure
business from a guy who went from
stocking shelves so now we're talking
about how do we scale it up Beyond him
he can only max out a certain amount of
clients and still uh you know serve them
properly uh do we bring on somebody else
underneath him and just keep increasing
the prices what kind of business did he
want to build
six figure business you know inside of
five months it's crazy right I mean
maybe not so crazy but from an idea to
action but didn't spend any money to
start it there were no ads that were
taken out is just research hard work
hustle Outreach
telling people he can help them and it
was him reaching out to people who he
thought could really benefit that he had
knowledge that could help them and
saying I'd love to set up a free call
with him and he set up these half an
hour calls we was walking through and
giving them advice and he had three big
ideas for each client and and most
people wouldn't then hire him like most
people who come on a call you're not
they're not going to hire you right away
um but you hit a certain percentage
right and you get better in targeting
who you're going to go after and reach
and so now we've built a six figure
business and plus now we're looking at
really scaling up for next year
and so
having this conversation I guess around
money how to build a business quickly
without having to spend money
um I think is important and so maybe
I'll try to include more of that content
love to know your thoughts uh that can
be the question of the day let me know
your thoughts you want more content
about making money uh on the channel you
can let me know in the comments below
but I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help you step
number one is don't start spending money
until you're making it don't spend money
until you're making it so easy to spend
money this is the thing when I was in
Venture Capital raising money for
companies
everybody just showed how they're going
to spend money but not how they're going
to make it right it's so easy to think
about if I only had ten thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars whatever you can go buy
all this stuff stop thinking about the
money you don't have right instead you
think about what you can do with what
you do have
what can you use your Genius you're
resourceful you've got ideas how do you
use that creativity instead of thinking
the biggest problem is money the problem
is not money the problem is you're not
resourceful enough go off and solve that
problem right Jeremy had a budget of
zero and still has a budget of zero to
build his business
and even if you're doing a product right
you say well he's doing a service great
maybe you actually start as a service
maybe your product idea should start as
a service to get close to your customers
and build a reliable repeatable income
stream but if you're going to do a
product you pre-sell right you pre-sell
you you make a you make a mock-up and if
you can't actually make like a mug to
show then you make a design of it right
you do a mock-up there's always a
smaller way to get started and you
pre-sell you're not putting enough
hustle energy heart dedication into it
and you're blaming lack of money too
many people maybe not you but too many
people that's the problem don't spend
money until you're making money it's a
great rule to start by number two is
study wealthy people who share the same
values as you this is this is where it
becomes particularly difficult because
you might look at some people who have
money who've made it and say well that
person is such a whatever right that
person is is evil or that person is
whatever like you come up with a story
in your mind and so even if you're
looking at YouTube whether you're
looking at my content or Gary or Grant
or Tom or Patrick or any of the Mel any
of the people creating content think
about first who do you resonate with on
values right maybe you love Gary and
hate grants or maybe you love Grant and
you hate Gary maybe you love Dan and
hate Evan right great awesome
go learn from that person go learn from
that person because the way that they
think about money could be the thing
that you need the most and so surround
yourself with them watch their videos
read their books go to their events to
see that somebody who has the same
values as you can make money so that's
possible so don't so that you don't feel
like I'm a nice guy or a nice girl and I
can never make money because I want to
rip people off there's lots of people
who are making lots of money and not
ripping people off so find your
favorites and model them and be around
them and surround yourself with them if
if only virtually like even if you never
meet them if only virtually so that
their way of thinking their thought
process and money starts to seep into
you and step number three is understand
that money lets you serve the more money
you have the more you can serve right
what happens if you're not making money
then this thing that you love doing this
is what this part the last section built
to serve if you guys don't have built
the serve you can pre-order in the link
below the last section I built to serve
the whole the first part is all about
finding your purpose right you were
built to serve how are you built to
serve the process is in here right
um the last section that was how to turn
it into a business because if you found
your call and if you found the thing
that is your purpose that you want to do
for the rest of your life but you can't
turn it into something that's going to
pay you the problem is you're just doing
it as a hobby for the rest of your life
and and there's nothing necessarily
wrong with that you're still helping
you're still giving you're still
contributing but you can only do it on
the evenings and weekends because you're
not making enough money to actually
support yourself so you have to have
this job that you know maybe you hate
maybe you don't hate but isn't actually
your thing and then when you get home
the last couple hours of the weekends
those hours you can use to fulfill your
purpose and that's great and that's
Noble but what if you could turn your
full-time thing into the thing that
fulfills your purpose so that one you're
happier because you're doing more work
on on the thing that you love doing
right but then two you can scale it up
you can hire people now and now instead
of just you part-time fulfilling your
purpose you have yourself and a whole
team of people of 10 100 a thousand
people all contributing towards your
mission which then allows you to give
right at every event that I do there's
always
usually aim for ten percent
um of people who who are in for free who
couldn't afford it
all right so on my tour when we go on
the workshop on the tour
um we're doing 20 something cities over
almost 90 days
ten percent of the room will be free
because they can't afford it because
maybe they're homeless you wouldn't know
it there's a lot of people who are
homeless that you would not know are
homeless right uh whenever I do my
thought Leadership Academy in Toronto
it's a it's a I don't know I forget what
the ticket is a couple thousand to come
um there's always somebody in the room
who's there on basically a sponsorship
right it's a it's a I want to say
donation it's uh what when you give to
education I don't know anyway
we let somebody in for free somebody who
can't afford it somebody who I believe
in who I think has a message and and
will take a lot from this training and
they get in for free and because I'm
making money that allows me to do that
if if I wasn't getting paid at all from
any of the people who come out then I
couldn't just do it all for free every
time because then I can't afford a
location I can't afford to have my team
members I couldn't be able to put it
together so understanding making that
shift in your head that money allows you
to serve the more money you make the
more you can serve the more you can help
people and if you actually want to
fulfill your purpose then you have to
learn how to make money in your business
rule number four find your drive most
people quit on things because they don't
have a powerful Mission or they don't
know where their Drive comes from
chasing an opportunity isn't enough
because you're going up against people
who love that thing who might be willing
to die for that thing if you want to go
to Mars you're competing against Elon
Musk who would die to go to Mars you
better absolutely love it or he's going
to crush you you need to find the thing
that you love that does not feel like
work otherwise you'll end up working
your entire life and hating it so every
Thursday when I'm in Toronto I do this
free event for Toronto entrepreneurs at
my dance studio trying to dance salsa
five to six pm Thursdays when I'm in the
city I do a free event q a session for
an hour come out meet me talk let's hang
out however I can help give back to the
community and help local entrepreneurs
my Thursdays are Bonkers my Thursdays
are all day long interviews Hangouts
podcasts Skype sessions one-on-ones my
assistant books them in 25 minute chunks
and I have 25 minutes on five minute
break in between usually I use that
break to get set up for the next one 25
minutes 5 25 5 25 5 the whole day long
and then I end up going to the studio I
record my podcast with Mark Drager I
then do two 30-minute one-on-ones that
we filmed for the YouTube channel and
then after all of that I do a one hour q
a for the entrepreneur community and
then after that I'm doing more meetings
with my team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
Thursday how do you have the energy for
all of that stuff
I love it like I I love being there with
the people that group session is is the
best for me I love it I'm not getting
paid for it it's free it's probably not
a great use of my time if I if I had to
pick for one hour what's the best use of
my time hang out with startup
entrepreneurs ask me their questions or
or do something like write my book or
make my next course or something else it
probably doesn't make the most sense but
I love it and so therefore it makes the
most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be torture and it
should be for me to jump into your
schedule should be torture I should look
at your calendar and say that's
ridiculous how do you have so much
energy for all that stuff and when you
jump in the mind it's like the exact
same for me when I gear up for Thursday
as an example when putting my sugar hat
on I gain energy as the day goes on I'm
not losing energy by the time I hit five
o'clock and I'm doing the group session
with people I'm carrying the energy of
all the entrepreneurs that I've met on
my 25 minute one-on-ones throughout the
entire day
I love it I gain more steam but most
things ask me to do almost anything else
for for 8 10 12 14 hours I would hate my
life ask me to make coffee for for 10
hours a day I would hate my life ask me
to play piano ask me to do almost
anything for that amount of time I would
hate my life because it feels like work
and so you have to find a thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it it actually gives you
energy so paying attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh
oh this sucks like that's a good signal
that you're doing the wrong thing
because you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are a genius you
should be crushing it at something and
if the work that you're doing is
draining your energy the people around
you are draining your energy chances are
you're in the wrong spot you're hanging
them with the wrong people you're doing
the wrong kind of work and so how do you
actually find the right kind of work I
got a process that's gonna save you it's
called who I how let's dive into it step
one is your who your who was your one
word most important core value and so
think about what if you had one core
value what is it for me it's believe
it's a part of everything that I do
think about who your favorite teacher
was growing up thinking about what your
favorite song is your favorite movie
this connective tissue there's a value
that you have there's one core value
that stands out above all the other ones
I wrote a book on it it's called your
one word go through the process it's one
of the most important things you can
ever do in your life as soon as you
figure what your one word is your who
then that shines a light on your life
right so for me it's belief it's shines
a light on every ear of my life on my on
my business on my relationships
everything and if you are not happy it's
because you are living out of alignment
with your who you're living out of
alignment with your one word most
important core value if I was unhappy in
my life it's because there's a lack of
belief somewhere
with a relationship in my business
something that has to be a lack of
belief it's the same thing for you
Alex's one word is belong Alex helps me
run trying to dance salsa we're changing
the whole brand and around TDS now to be
around belong because that's his one
word and he's going to bring
belongingness what do we sell at TDS not
just how to do dance moves it's
belongingness
people lack belongingness and a sense of
community come to TDs we'll take care of
you and so what's your one word what's
your most important core value most
people have no idea what it is and so
you're walking aimlessly through life
figure this out it is one of the most
important exercises you will ever do in
your life what's your who step two is
your why understand that your purpose
comes from your pain the people who go
on to do amazing things likely suffered
a lot I've never seen somebody go up and
crush it and have amazing results in any
area of life without coming from some
source of suffering a lot of pain
growing up at some point whatever you
struggled with whatever you suffered
with whatever the most painful moment of
your life is ask yourself what is the
most painful moment of all time in my
life what is that thing when you figure
it out understand this you're why your
purpose will be for the rest of your
life helping people who are currently
going through the thing that you went
through I love helping entrepreneurs
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I felt worthless as an
entrepreneur I felt worthless as a human
being when I was in my first business
that was bringing no value that was
getting no results I felt terrible
ashamed embarrassed alone
and that's why I do what I do I want to
help entrepreneurs not struggle as much
as I struggle that's my why and you're
who and your why is for life
I want to believe in entrepreneurs why
why believe I told you the story why
entrepreneurs I told you the story I
could believe in anybody but
entrepreneurs are going to be people for
me for life for life that never goes
away and that's more clarity than 99 of
the world has just figuring out your who
and your why is more clarity than most
of the world
the last part is the how who why how how
becomes how you're going to help people
get through it so however you got
through it whatever you struggled with
that you made your way through even if
you're not fully through it yet
but you're better than when you were
before right when you were in the hall
when you're at the worst moment of your
life the person who you are today could
go back and talk to that person and give
them some advice and help them there's a
lot of people who are currently in that
situation that you were in
and how you got out of it is a recipe
for other people how did I get out of it
for me as an entrepreneur was modeling
success was looking at who else has
built successful companies that I can
copy and model apply to my business Bill
Gates saved my company even though I
never met him because I looked at the
strategies every went to zero to one now
what have I done for the past 20 years
share strategy of some famous
entrepreneurs on my website now on my
YouTube channel on my Instagram that's
what I do I love sharing my own voice
and also DJing other people's content
because I want to learn from Steve Jobs
I want to learn from Kanye West I want
to learn from Oprah I want to learn from
these people and I want you to do too
and so the path that you took through
isn't just his isolated incident it
becomes a recipe that other people can
model as well and you can teach it your
how will evolve mullen's success when I
started was books I was reading books I
was reading biographies now it's making
YouTube videos in 10 years it might be
virtual reality or hologram ever beaming
into your room right it's gonna change
the how will change that as technology
evolves but you're who and your why are
for life and so if you don't feel like
you're motivated if you don't have the
drive if you don't know your mission go
through the process you're who you're
why or how do it take the time it it
will it will revolutionize not just your
business but your life and you're set up
to follow that path for the rest of your
life so it's worth a 5 10 15 60 Minute
session to sit down and try to figure it
out rule number five the last one before
our very special bonus clip create your
own path I think too many people are
trying to live someone else's path
you're trying to follow your parents
path you're trying to be the next
Michael Jordan or the next Wayne Gretzky
or the next Steve Jobs you're trying to
be the next somebody else where if your
goal is to be the next somebody else
you're always going to fall short you
can't out Steve Steve it's not happening
it's not going to be possible so you
will always fall short if you are trying
to follow somebody else's path the key
is to create your own unique path that's
where you're going to stand out and
that's where the magic is gonna happen
you already are unique you already are
the first and only version of you that
will ever walk this planet that has
already happened but you're not the best
you yet you're the unique you you're the
first you but you're not the best you
yet and that's where you can pull from
people you can pull from jobs you can
pull from Gates and you can pull from
Winfrey and you can pull from LeBron you
can pull from all these people to make
you the best version of you and help you
go off on your path and it starts by
understanding what your one word is
living your life on purpose knowing what
your values are and having the
self-awareness to create something that
is important and then by embracing the
genius at the end where the unique
talents that you have get mashed up
together in a way that nobody else can
execute on and it often comes by I want
to do this or I want to do this or I
want to do this and you've got two or
three or four things that you don't know
which direction to take and the real
answer is to smash all of those things
together because that's the unique thing
that only you can do anybody can be a
banker anybody can be a salsa dancer
anybody can be a gamer anybody can be a
fill in the blank but when you start
combining those things together and then
combine it with your one word which is
your value system that's something that
nobody else can do it's something nobody
else can touch now you're off creating
your own path and being the best version
of you and that's where your ultimate
success happiness wealth and impact will
come create your own path
you need to do things that make you
proud of yourself you need to do the
difficult things when it's hard and you
do it and you try and you keep going
that's when you feel proud about
yourself when you quit early even if
everybody gives you a logical reason for
doing say hey it's okay don't worry
about it quit you should quit take it
easy but you know deep down inside
yourself
you can't quit you have to do the work
that makes you feel proud because if you
face difficulties and then quit that's
what you're teaching yourself that's a
story inside your head and there's no
way you're going to go off and
accomplish those big bad Impossible
Dream goals of yours if you quit every
time it gets hard
I had a guy come to my Columbus Workshop
and he had a goal to do six days a week
cold showers
it was Friday night
Saturday night was his day off from cold
showers it was Friday Night comes to my
workshop and says it's been winter here
in Columbus I'm at my girlfriend's house
all day today it's been freezing been
inside I've been inside the house has
been freezing all day I didn't do my
cold shower today
Evan what should I do should I take my
cold shower
I said well are you proud of the reason
why not
are you proud of the reason that you're
in a cold house all day and so that's
that's good justification for you said
no I'm not proud of the reason
great then you have to do it you have to
go take your cold shower
and after the workshop he got home at 11
30 at night and he took an Instagram
video from from the waist up getting
into the cold shower and freezing his
face off and then I said you have to go
off and do it again tomorrow too even
though Saturday's your day off you have
to get up and do it again tomorrow just
to show yourself just to prove to
yourself What You're Made Of when it's
difficult and you try that's when you
win that's when you actually feel good
about yourself when it's difficult and
you keep going
even if the results suck even if past
the 40 your results are starting to
decline
you feel great about yourself because
you kept going
but if you quit as soon as it gets hard
that's what you're teaching yourself to
do and so I see entrepreneurs and
leaders as trees
you're a tree
your responsibility as a tree is to eat
poison
carbon dioxide right you eat poison
you eat it you grow from it and then you
spit out positivity and oxygen for the
people around you right for yourself and
the people around you you grow from it
your job is to eat adversity your job is
to eat judgment your job is to eat
difficulties
and you grow from it and then you create
opportunities and possibilities for
yourself and the people around you
that's your job
and so the next time that you find
yourself in a difficult situation you
want to quit you want to give up you're
at that Mark your brain wants to quit on
you
remind yourself I'm a tree
I'm a tree I'm going to grow from this
this is my chance to get better
this is my chance to eat it to grow from
it and then create possibilities for
other people
that's your job
if you want to be an amazing leader and
an amazing entrepreneur and I'm cheering
for you
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome and if you want to watch Evan's
top 10 rules for Success check out the
video next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
the next Evan is on the other side of
even more belief self-belief comes from
doing difficult things so the more that
you do something that you didn't think
you're capable of doing all of a sudden
you say oh I can't do it every time
there's something hard in front of you
that then you